christian ranucci condamnés à mort et
exécutés en 76 sera-t-il rejugé la
commission de révision de la cour de
cassation s'est réuni ce matin
elle rendra sa décision dans une
quinzaine de jours rappel des faits
clément weill-raynal christian ranucci
lors de son arrestation en juin 1974
le jeune homme connu pour son caractère
fragile vient d'avouer aux policiers
être l'assassin de la petite maria
dolorès rambla dont le corps a été
retrouvé quelques jours auparavant dans
une carrière au dessus de marseille
plus tard au cours de l'instruction
ranucci se rétracte mais la machine
judiciaire est enclenchée ranucci sera
condamné à mort puis guillotiné en
juillet 1976
depuis maintenant quinze ans la famille
et les amis de christian ranucci demande
régulièrement la révision du procès pour
la défense la condamnation de christian
ranucci en dépit de ses aveux est une
effroyable erreur judiciaire
de nombreuses pièces du dossier négligée
lors du procès innocenterait le jeune
homme des témoins essentiels auraient
été oubliés des procès verbaux
surchargées des pièces à conviction
comme le fameux pull-over rouge aurait
été mal exploité la décision de la cour
de cassation de réviser ou non le procès
sera connue dans une quinzaine de jours
et la colère ni self